Jetzt wurde eine weitere wirklich unfassbare
Eigenschaft von wahrscheinlich zahlreichen
Schwarzen Löchern aufgedeckt.
Aber erstmal ist das spezielle Schwarze Loch,
das jetzt vermessen werden konnte, etwas ganz
besonders: Denn es dreht sich fast mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
- und stößt damit an die Grenzen der Einstein’schen
Relativitätstheorie.
Heißt das etwa, dass es tatsächlich sogar
das ganze Universum mitreißen könnte?
Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
kein Video.
Herzliche willkommen.
Ein super spannendes Thema, das ihr Euch über
die Whats App-Community gewünscht habt - lieben
Dank dafür.
Auf genau zwei Methoden können Forschungsteams
weltweit derzeit zurückgreifen, um Schwarze
Löcher zu vermessen.
Spannend ist zum einen die Masse und zum anderen
eben die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit des jeweiligen
Schwarzen Loches.
Diese Drehrate ist eine dimensionslose Einheit
und kann von 0 bis zu einem maximalen Wert
von 1 reichen.
Ein internationales Forschungsteam hat jetzt
ein Schwarzes Loch untersucht, das einen unglaublichen
Wert von 0,9 erreicht.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Wissenschaftler,
Sudip Bhattacharyya: „Wenn Schwarze Löcher
entstehen, sind Masse und Spinrate zwei Eigenschaften,
die sie charakterisieren.
Dabei kann die Masse deutlich einfacher gemessen
werden als die Rotation, da die Masse aufgrund
der Schwerkraft einen großen Einfluss auf
die Entstehung eines Schwarzen Lochs hat”.
Die durchgeführten Messungen der Spinrate
sind also ein voller Erfolg für die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler.
Ausschlaggebend dabei waren die Röntgenstrahlen,
die das Objekt aussendet.
Diese entstehen dadurch, dass es Gas und Staub
verschluckt.
Durch die Messung dieser Strahlung gelang
es dem Astronomen-Team, die Rotationsrate
mit dem unglaublichen Wert von 0,9 zu bestimmen.
Das Objekt wurde übrigens bereits vor zwei
Jahren von Indiens erstem Satellit namens
“AstroSat” aufgespürt.
Konkret befindet sich das Schwarze Loch in
dem Doppelsternsystem “4U 1630-47”.
Das Schwarze Loch dreht sich also fast in
Lichtgeschwindigkeit - diese liegt bei 299.792.458
Metern pro Sekunde.
Und somit kratzt es tatsächlich an die Grenzen
der Relativitätstheorie von Albert Einstein.
Denn nach Einsteins Theorie führt ein schnell
rotierendes schwarzes Loch dazu, dass sich
der Raum selbst dreht.
Physikalisch gesehen bedingen solche Schwarzen
Löcher durch ihre enorme Gravitation eine
entsprechend große Veränderung der geometrischen
Struktur von Raum und Zeit- also der sogenannten
Raumzeitkrümmung.
Doch die Raumzeit wird vereinfacht gesagt
nicht nur durch das Schwarze Loch gekrümmt;
es reißt sie sogar aufgrund seiner Rotation
mit.
Konkret bedeutet das also: Alle Objekte um
das Schwarze Loch werden mitgedreht, denn:
Auch die Raumzeit selbst dreht sich mit!
Das jetzt vermessene Objekt gehört übrigens
zu den einigen wenigen Schwarzen Löchern,
bei denen bislang eine solch hohe Rotationsgeschwindigkeit
nachgewiesen werden konnte.
Auch deswegen ist das Forschungsteam so dermaßen
geflasht von diesem Ergebnis.
Noch ist die Studie allerdings noch in keinem
wissenschaftlichen Fachmagazin veröffentlicht
- dies soll jedoch demnächst im Fachblatt
“The Astrophysical Journal” passieren.
Doch auch der NASA-Satellit “Chandra”
konnte die spannenden Ergebnisse bereits bestätigen.
Dazu Bhattacharyya: “Dies ist die erste
Kooperation zwischen Indien und den USA, in
der AstroSat und Chandra für die Untersuchung
von Schwarzen Löchern eingesetzt wurden.
Da es sehr erfolgreich war, wollen wir jetzt
auch andere Kooperationen angehen.
“Denn auch, wenn wir immer mehr zu den Schwarzen
Löchern selbst erfahren, stellen sie uns
doch im Großen und Ganzen noch vor große
Rätsel.
Durch den Chandra-Satelliten beispielsweise,
der ein Röntgenteleskop am Start hat, konnte
die NASA bereits vor einiger Zeit spannende
Erkenntnisse zu Schwarzen Löchern sammeln,
die sich derart schnell drehen.
Fest steht: Alles, was ihnen zu nahe kommt,
wird verschluckt.
Vorher aber sammelt sich die Materie in der
sogenannten Akkretionsschreibe - einer schnell
rotierenden Scheibe.
Und genau diese Akkretionsscheibe schießt
gigantische Materiestrahlen aus vielen Schwarzen
Löchern heraus - senkrecht nach oben und
unten ins All.
Und das sind die sogenannten Jets, die man
sich tatsächlich vorstellen kann wie Fontänen.
Forschungsteams vermuten schon seit längerem,
dass die Jets wohl aus Nickel und Eisen bestehen
und mit unglaublichen 200.000 Kilometern PRO
SEKUNDE ins All schießen - das sind zwei
Drittel der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Forschungsteams wissen immer noch nicht ganz
genau, wie diese sogenannten “Jets” entstehen.
Doch nach Auswertung der Chandra-Daten ist
die Energie solcher Jets wohl zum einen von
der Masse und zum anderen eben vom Drehmoment
des Schwarzen Lochs abhängig.
Und hiermit schließt sich der Kreis, denn:
Die Auswertung von Chandra-Daten legt nahe,
dass sich solche Schwarzen Löcher wohl nahe
ihrer maximalen Geschwindigkeit drehen müssen.
Solche detaillierten Untersuchungen zu Schwarzen
Löchern bewerten Forschungsteams weltweit
übrigens als besonders wichtig, da sich somit
grundlegende Theorien zum Universum überprüfen
und testen lassen.
Es ist schon wahnsinn, was wir immer wieder
für grundlegende Erkenntnisse über das Weltall
erfahren und täglich kommen neue hinzu und
wir bei Clixoom berichten darüber.
Wenn ihr kein Video verpassen wollt, dann
abonniert auch den englischen Kanal von Clixoom.
Auch da gibt es immer mehr Videopremieren.
Einfach hier klicken und darunter geht es
weiter mit: New revolutionary space propulsion
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned, see you soon.